Hallo herzlich willkommen zur ukw unsere kleine welt sendet wieder ein bisschen ich bin tim love.
Und wer das programm hier von anfang an verfolgt hat und sich vielleicht noch erinnern an die kleine pilot sendung die ich ganz am anfang mit nicolas und reinhard gemacht habe damals noch live auf der bühne.
Auf dem chaos communication kongress wo.
Wir die ganze zeit so die sinnfrage dieses formats gestellt wurde und nicht immer gesagt habe ja keine ahnung was ich nicht wohin das läuft
letzter zeit könnte man so ein bisschen den eindruck gehabt haben ukw steht für watch weil zu viel auf brexit ging aber so grundsätzlich auch mit dem hongkong thema.
Ja war das so ein bisschen auslandsjournal hier so ein kleines und keine ahnung ob das jetzt so verfängt.
Aber grundsätzlich habe ich festgestellt scheint ganz praktisch zu sein bestimmte prozesse die so auf der welt stattfinden.
Die sich irgendwo potenziell sehr langwierig dahin schieben und die vielleicht dann immer mit so einer tagesmutter aufnahme gar nicht ausreichend beschrieben sind,
mehr oder weniger regelmäßig mal wieder zu beleuchten um mal vorbeizuschauen so was da passiert.
Mal gucken trotzdem habe ich auch noch vor mir das ein bisschen anders anzureichern aber heute,
machen wir mal ein thema was in dieses von mir eben skizziertes schema.
Ganz gut reinpassen könnte und wer nicht komplett unter dem stein gelebt hat wird ja festgestellt haben dass das wort corona.
Bin eines jahres eine ganz binnen eines viertel jahres eine ganz neue oder was haben wir denn jetzt eigentlich anfang märz naja bitte innerhalb von zwei monaten eigentlich eine komplett neue bedeutung bekommen hat auch wenn sie die schon vorher hatte.
Sprich der virus geht um dreh dich nicht um und mittlerweile befindet sich zumindest europa auch auf dem besten wege dahin ein mehr oder weniger vollständigen shutdown durchzumachen,
naja und das ist ja dann schon ganz signifikant also dachte ich mir kann man ja vielleicht mal anfangen darüber zu reden mal gucken vielleicht wird das ja auch ein thema,
was nochmal häufiger begleitet werden muss so aber ich rede ja nicht so gerne alleine und ich weiß ja auch mal nicht so viel und deswegen habe ich mir wieder verstärkung reingeholt und das ist heute pavel hallo,
paul.
Wir kennen uns schon sehr lange wir haben schon ganz viele podcast zusammengemacht weniger jetzt auf diesem kanal also hier noch gar nicht getraut zu sein aber so was bei der freakshow mal zu gast et cetera.
Das heißt die ein oder andere hörerin mag dich schon mal im ohr haben aber.
Ohne jetzt vielleicht dazu weit ausholen zu wollen,
was ich bei dir schätze ist dass wenn irgendwas ist da schaust du das meistens sehr genau an und das versuche ich zwar auch aber ich.
Fitte irgendwie du hast es dann noch ein bisschen mehr raus mit mit dem detail deswegen dachte ich mir wäre das vielleicht mal eine ganz gute paarung heute,
mal so ein bisschen aufzuwachen was eigentlich bisher so passiert ist und was ja was vielleicht auch noch passieren könnte und um vielleicht nochmal einen kleinen disclaimer nochmal vorneweg ich habe jetzt hier nicht vor so einem.
First responder corona virus alles was ihr wissen müsst podcast zu machen weil erstens.
Kann ich das gar nicht zweitens wollen wir das auch nicht drittens machen das vor allem andere viel viel viel besser was ich zum beispiel bemerkenswert jetzt gerade finde ist ja wahrscheinlich auch schon über den weg gelaufen und an der stelle finde ich halt auch podcast,
also kann man es einfach nur nochmal wieder ganz laut beklatscht mache ich ja eh schon seit fünfzehn jahren aber jetzt passt es eigentlich wirklich,
was hat der ndr gemacht haben gesagt so corona schwierig suchen uns nochmal ein experten machen wir doch einfach mal schnell mal eben ein neues format auf so und na klar macht man das als podcast in dieser zeit.
Anstatt dass irgendwie zu versuchen in so einen vierundzwanzig stunden rhythmus auf ukw.
Zu packen ja wurde einfach dieser kleine corolla virus update podcast gemacht jeden tag eine halbe stunde mit dem leiter der geologie.
An der charité in berlin christian trosten ja so der typische wissenschaftler slash mediziner ist so.
Hat eine meinung,
hat aber vor allem den ganzen hintergrund versteht die ganzen sachen und erläutert das dann auch und fühlt sich dabei unglaublich wohl in der situation in so einem podcast zu sein,
wo er endlich mal ausreden kann damit die leute die ganze zeit unterbrechen und das ist das dachte ich mir nur so ja genau genau das,
genau aber wir wollen mal unseren blick wagen um und weil wir ja auch gestern noch eingesehen haben,
also wenn wir jetzt sowieso alle bald in unseren zimmern verschwinden dann gibt's natürlich einen unheimlichen podcast bedarf.
Der muss natürlich auch gedeckt werden.
Ganz genau zumal das dann mit der nachproduktion auch ein bisschen stocken könnte unter umständen dann.
Man weiß ja nicht es war alles remote machen wie hast du denn so die zeit erlebt die zwei monate.
Also erstmal was ich so gehört habe es ist weit weg das ist in china so und.
Was ja auch schon mal saß.
Ja ja genau wir hatten saß und märz.
Vogelgrippe.
Und das ist alles ja nicht so schlimm geworden na ja gut
es diesmal dann habe ich die sterblichkeitsrate gesehen das sei jetzt auch nicht so aus wie ebola oder wie sogar wie saß wo teilweise wirklich dreißig prozent der infizierten irgendwie in lebensgefahr
sind also dachte ich mir naja das ist so ungefähr so eine neue art von grippe und
wer weiß ob und wann das das hier auftaucht hat mir also erst mal den
sozusagen nach dem ersten blick war ich erstmal da nicht nicht weiter beunruhigt so
und als dann so vor ich sag mal zwei wochen so die erste panik welle irgendwie durchs land lief und die leute anfing plötzlich ja die supermärkte leer zu kaufen,
einzulagern und insbesondere klopapier wenn das mit dem klopapier
kann ich mir überhaupt nicht verstehen so weil da gibt's doch ja jetzt doch problemlos jede menge alternativen zu jeder hat eine handbrause zum beispiel meistens oder
ja
Die leute sind nicht mehr gewohnt.
Also klopapier ist nur finde ich der dass das geringste problem als klopapier ist immer noch knapp also ich war heute morgen nochmal einkaufen und
bei rewe war immer noch also das teure es ist ein bisschen teures klopapier noch da aber so ansonsten fünf leere regal meter wo sonst irgendwie ein zwei drei vier fünf lag ich
alles weg so und auch noch kein nachschub wahrscheinlich mal eine these war auch noch das halt klopapier nicht so viel wert ist und die wenn die transportkapazitäten
gerade knapp ist dass die laster lieber mit was anderem vollpacken als mit billigen klopapier so vom volumen her das heißt es wahrscheinlich deswegen auch nachschub nicht so schnell,
kommt aber.
Zu denken aber die käufer nicht.
Nee nee also.
Die haben einfach nur die wollen einfach nur ihre fäkal situation geklärt wissen.
Ja ansonsten ist die versorgungssituation aber wie gesagt,
scheint mir eigentlich ziemlich gut zu sein so hier und da so einzelne produkte komischerweise so apfelsaft zum beispiel dein lieblingsapfel saft war nicht da so.
Viel interessanter ist zu gucken was nicht gekauft wird.
Weil du siehst ja sozusagen in diesen situationen ganz klar was was leute auch für sich selbst als luxus sehen und was sie irgendwie auch dann nicht kaufen würden wenn es wenn es andere alle schon leer ist.
Das ist natürlich schwierig zu sagen weil wie gesagt fast also ich würde sagen neunundneunzig komma neun prozent der produkte waren einfach da,
in ausreichenden mengen auch alles wurden mittlerweile ran geschafft egal ob nudeln oder zucker oder mehl oder was auch immer so auch beim haltbaren geschichten also eigentlich die supermärkte sind mehr oder weniger voll.
Solange die lastwagen noch fahren können.
Ja wobei ich glaube selbst in italien gut weil
weiß ich nicht aber sagen so versorgungs- direkt für versorgungsengpässe sehe ich nicht das problem
was man halt natürlich haben könntest wenn man entweder selber irgendwie erkrankt oder in seiner umgebung jemand und man halt in selbst quarantäne geht und nicht draußen rumlaufen will
wer kauft dann für ein ein war ja dann auch meistens die ganze familie eigentlich potenziell so das ist eigentlich dann der case wo
sagen würde okay wenn man davor wenn man das befürchtet so dann kann es sinn machen aber.
Da werden wir auf jeden fall noch noch drüber quatschen bleiben vielleicht erstmal so ein bisschen bei diesen zwei monaten und wie sich das alles angebahnt hat also mir ging's ja nicht anders als dir erstmal war das alles relativ weit weg und.
Die italien situation bei aber dann schon so ein kleiner schocker weil so wie sie es jetzt ja abzeichnet.
Ist es wohl so dass dort einfach es wohl schon sehr früh eine infektion gegeben hat die aber einfach lange zeit nicht.
Entdeckt wurde weil man nicht ausreichend.
Drauf geschaut hat oder nicht ausreichend sensibilisiert war oder weiß ich nicht equipment nicht hatte.
Das problem nicht so gesehen hat die leute noch nicht so drauf waren also von mir für eine winter podcast wirklich sehr sehr interessant so und bringt auch ein paar aspekte auf,
die ganz gut erklären können warum das auch so schwierig ist das so rauszumachen klar du hast natürlich jetzt auf einmal die fälle von leuten denen es irgendwie,
schlecht geht die sterblichkeitsrate scheint aber derzeit immer noch sich vor allem auf ältere leute zu beziehen.
Naja also erstmal vielleicht zu italien italien ist wenn ich mir die zahlen angucke ist uns ungefähr nur neun tage voraus also es geht jetzt nicht um irgendwie wochen und monate sondern.
Das bezieht sich aber nur auf die infizierten zahlen die man hat die auch sehr davon abhängen was man testen kann.
Ganz anders was die modalität betrifft also sind dort einfach sehr viele männer und das deswegen erwähne ich das auch weil das war seine aussage dass,
man eben von sehr viel mehr infizierten als bekanntes ausgehen muss so und schon man sozusagen an den todes zahlen sehen kann dass es dort noch in einer anderen dimension ist als hier.
Das ist das ist genau der punkt dass halt die zahl der toten tatsächlich ganz gute rückschlüsse darauf lässt über den wahren verbreitung
grad und ja also,
wahrscheinlich man die offiziellen zahlen sind gerade irgendwie für italien zwölftausendvierhundert achtundsechzig und vermutlich sind es aber hunderttausende mittlerweile
so anhand der der zahlen gut die zweite sache was ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig macht was ich was man auch rausgefunden hat dass solange das gesundheitssystem funktioniert,
liegt man irgendwie bei null komma fünf bis ein prozent irgendwo bei.
Der anteil der menschen die sterben in dem moment wo aber die intensiv versorgung
nicht mehr gewährleistet ist oder sogar ja jetzt diese korporale sauerstoffversorgung also quasi so eine maschine so eine externe lunge an die man dann angeschlossen wird
dann geht es eher in vier bis auf vier bis fünf prozent hoch im schnitt also drei bis fünf prozent waren so die die zahlen das heißt so ein funktionierendes gesundheitssystem schafft halt,
wir sagen ja vier von fünf leuten ungefähr das leben zu retten die halt sonst wenn man sie nicht intensiv versorgt sterben halt rund fünf mal mehr leute
als mit funktionierenden gesundheitssystem.
Das ist ja auch in woran so beobachtet worden die man hat eine extrem hohe modalität in der stadt.
Da wo halt einfach alles an seiner belastungsgrenze schnell war auf dem land wiederum wo es noch die kapazitäten gab.
War die halt extrem viel geringer.
Schließt sich natürlich die frage an wie viel kapazitäten gibt's denn bei uns so und,
schaffen wir das was ja im moment das ziel der politik oder das dilemma auch so ein bisschen ist dass man ja eigentlich sagen gerne schon
das laufen lassen möchte eigentlich nicht so drastische maßnahmen nicht nicht alles runter fahren möchte sondern es irgendwie lang die welle
so reiten dass es gerade unterhalb der freien kapazität unseres gesundheitssystems bleibt das war jedenfalls klang so bis bisher als das was die politik gerne tun
würde.
Klar weil das hält ja dann sozusagen auch die sonstigen auswirkungen niedrig.
Weil das wird sicherlich schon also,
mein macht hat bereits schon eine gewaltige delle in die weltwirtschaft gemacht und es wird sicherlich noch weiter bemerkbar bleiben so aber wenn ich nochmal zurück zu diesem dilemma,
in der politik so das eine problem ist natürlich wenn man jetzt frühzeitig reagiert,
dann und alles geht gut dann heißt es irgendwie die haben mal wieder übertrieben viel zu viel alarm gemacht ist ja gar nichts passiert so das ist.
So oder,
hört man immer wieder die stimmen so nach dem motto naja irgendwie an grippe sind schon hunderte von leuten dieses jahr gestorben redet kein mensch drüber und jetzt wollen sie hier sagen die stadt dicht machen oder alles alles dicht machen
nur weil ja irgendwie in deutschland irgendwo zwei leute gestorben
sind so und das scheint offensichtlich auch so ein bisschen die sicht der politik bisher zu sein also jedenfalls wenn man sich dann anguckt senat wie gesagt tagt,
der berliner senat tag zeit einmal die woche so was.
Zu dem thema oder gehen.
Thema her zu dem thema also.
Bestimmt auch nicht mehr lange.
Genau also dienstag sitzen die wohl das nächste mal zusammen planmäßig habe ich,
gehört so aber bis dahin ja scheint die dinge erstmal so zu laufen ja aber wie gesagt nochmal zurück zum zum dilemma so also,
harte sofort reaktionen als schwierig durchsetzbar weil irgendwie die bedrohung offensichtlich also muss halt,
eine gewisse bedrohung erst da sein problem ist,
natürlich mit jedem tag den jetzt den die maßnahmen dann später kommen so haben wir im moment keine nachdem sag mal rund dreißig prozent mehr,
an
patienten in der spitze anschließend so oder infizierte in der spitze so und das kann er natürlich wenn's wenn's dann sehr sehr groß wird so.
Was meinst du mit genau mit in der spitze.
Naja.
Also interessanterweise machen solche pandemien alle verlaufen nach einer bestimmten kurve sodass es typischerweise so eine.
Sicher auch richards oder generalisierte logistik funktion das ist im prinzip so eine s-kurve.
Ab
geleitet von der oder wem das was sagt sigmund das heißt es ist fängt halt flach unten an steigt an kehrt sich irgendwann um und wird dann wieder oben flach also so ein bisschen wie eine kurve.
So und,
auch wenn man sich ich habe da mal spaßeshalber auf die chinesischen zahlen die berichtet wurden habe ich mal so eine funktion gefettet und siehe da
man findet halt parameter die,
egal wie die wie das verläuft so dass das passt ziemlich gut das heißt wir können davon ausgehen dass es sagen die zahl der insgesamt,
erkrankten irgendwann also irgendwann stoppt es irgendwann geht es nicht mehr weiter und,
die frage ist halt nur wie wie verläuft die kurve und wo an welchem level zu sagen was wird die zahl der maximal.
Infizierten sein
so zum wenn das wenn das ganze zum stehen kommt gut jetzt man hört immer wieder auch von der kanzlerin okay oder monologe gut fünfzig sechzig siebzig prozent werden wahrscheinlich
erkranken am am ende nur wenn man jetzt nach china guckt,
chinesen haben's bei ungefähr hunderttausend oder was was achtzigtausend ungefähr zum stehen gebracht das ganze.
Und so wird es
wird es halt hier auch laufen irgendwann wird zum stehen kommen nur die frage ist wo und jeden tag den wir mit jedem tag bei dem wir weiter warten dass sozusagen der punkt wo es zum stehen kommt dreißig prozent,
höher.
Als am tag davor.
Als am tag davor so gut bis halt natürlich irgendwann gut diese fünfzig sechzig prozent sind eine absolute obergrenze also wie er sich das dahin entwickelt.
Wenn wir jetzt nochmal zurückgehen sagen zu der zu der frage so wie habe ich reagiert eigentlich bin ich
jetzt erst seit ein paar tagen etwas beunruhigt und zwar seitdem ich mir halt angefangen habe ein bisschen mit den zahlen zu spielen weil ich wollte einfach nur wissen
weil niemand konnte mir sagen wie sieht's denn in der wieviel leute werden denn in einer woche oder in zwei wochen eigentlich voraussichtlich infiziert.
Sein so und ich wollte einfach mal selber gucken kann ich das anhand der bisherigen zahlen
herausfinden weil es eine einfache übung so man guckt sich an was ist das für eine kurve und findet da eine drauf und rechnet dann
einfach weiter und ich habe dann erstmal mit einer normalen exponentiell funktion angefangen und
da muss man sagen auch wenn,
am anfang also wenn das exponentiell ansteigt ist es schon so dass gleichzeitig der exponenten aber kleiner wird das heißt jede exponentiell funktion die man da jetzt erstmal findet wenn man die zahlen anguckt
es wächst dann trotzdem langsamer als als bisschen langsamer als,
also es verlangsamt sich so also der exponentielle anstieg verlangsamt sich aber insgesamt natürlich ist es trotzdem noch ein exponentielles anstieg das heißt wenn man das kaffee macht sieht man dass die tatsächlichen zahlen bisschen jeweils drunter,
liegen ja und.
Das war sozusagen der moment als ich das als ich dann selber die zahlen aus china gesehen hab gesehen habe,
wie drastisch die wann agiert haben und wie lange das gedauert hat bis das dann zum stopp gekommen ist also man kann sagen in china ungefähr,
ja war nach der also hat wenn man bis jetzt die die die phase für die zahlen gibt ungefähr acht wochen.
Ist so dich und mit fünf wochen zahlen konnte ich dann den ausgang vorausberechnen,
das heißt sozusagen drei wochen vor ende der acht wochen hätte man dann sagen können mit dem modell ok in drei wochen ist es jetzt wahrscheinlich vorbei und wird sich dann bei ja.
Also das hast du im nachgang festgestellt.
Das habe ich im nachgang genau das habe ich im nachgang also ich habe mir halt die zahlen genommen habe dann die kurve drauf gepackt und hab dann sozusagen,
sagen die vorhersage immer weiter also das coffee ting sagen immer weiter daten weggenommen vom schluss und geguckt wie viel daten kann ich eigentlich wegnehmen
bis und und trotzdem kommt halt die kurve noch dabei raus und da konnte ich halt sozusagen die letzten drei wochen an daten konnte ich halt.
Wegnehmen und hat dann trotzdem ganz ganz gut gepasst so und wenn man jetzt einfach sagt gut.
Es wird bei uns so laufen wie in china ungefähr so wenn man sich wenn man sich daran orientiert.
Dann kann man sagen,
von dem moment an wo es drastische maßnahmen gibt also wirklich dann ja die leute zu hause bleiben müssen sind so.
Drei wochen also zwei es dauert dann aber auch nochmal zwei wochen bis ich das in den zahlen bemerkbar macht die chinesen,
wir haben jetzt knapp was fünf fünf wochen ungefähr gebraucht von dem moment wo sie wirklich drastisch gesagt haben jetzt stopp bis lang der anstieg aufgehört,
hat.
Klar was er auch ein bisschen was mit der inkubation zeit zu tun hat wie lange dieser virus.
Offenbar ansteckend ist also so hatte ich das bisher verstanden habe ist ja erstmal der.
Das hauptproblem ist man kriegt den virus man ist ansteckend.
Aber er hat noch keine symptome für eine woche so und das hat halt,
sozusagen viele leute einfach es unmöglich gemacht sich entsprechend verantwortungsvoll zu verhalten weil wenn man nichts hat hat man halt nichts oder denke ich mir auch so ja was was habt ihr denn alle so geht's doch super
und offenbar ist es aber dann so dass wenn man zwei wochen lang diesen virus in sich hatte ganz unabhängig davon ob man da,
bisschen krank gar nicht krank bisschen krank schwer krank geworden ist,
wenn man die zeit dann durchgestanden hat also vor allem natürlich wenn man es überlebt hat so aber dann ist der virus nicht mehr.
Ansteckend aus weiß ich nicht ob man das schon so genau weiß warum das eigentlich so ist aber man glaubt zumindest das zu wissen bisher ist ja an dieser zwei wochen einschätzung hat sich ja nicht so sehr viel dran geändert also es scheint schon sich ein wenig zu.
Eine belastbare information zu handeln das heißt wir müssen im prinzip wenn wir.
Richtig der kurve da so eine bremse ansetzen wollten müssen wir verhindern.
Dass wir in kontakt kommen so wer auch immer den virus hat muss ihnen möglichst bei sich behalten damit er sich nicht wieder durch die weitergabe wieder,
neu replizieren kann und ansteckungsgefahr bleibt und im idealfall wenn alle irgendwie so.
Zwei wochen einfach innehalten würden und niemand mehr berühren würden was.
Nicht so ganz geht dann dann würde der irgendwie verrecken und wer dann vielleicht auch mehr oder weniger komplett weg.
Ja also sobald diese ältere produktionszeit unter eins geht also lange jeder der infiziert wird weniger als eine person
ansteckt läuft sich das ganze,
tot so dass es einfach die mathematik und natürlich wenn es auf null ist sozusagen wenn wenn die reproduktion quasi auf null runter ist dann hast du in in vierzehn tagen ist alles vorbei wenn sie jetzt nicht
wenn sie jetzt ein bisschen größer null
ist also zwischen null und eins sich bewegt läuft es halt ein bisschen langsamer aus weil sich doch trotzdem noch leute anstecken aber trotzdem sagen mit r
mit der reproduktion sobald die kleine eins ist weiß man ist es nur eine frage der zeit bis der virus einfach weg ist weil ja,
einfache mathematik oder heißt ja
man muss halt die reproduktion unter null kriegen das passiert irgendwann auch von ganz alleine nämlich wenn man hinreichend viele leute immunität entwickelt haben wenn die will nicht fünfzig sechzig siebzig achtzig prozent wieviel auch immer
sich dann angesteckt haben wobei es offenbar so ist.
Ich gehört habe das ungefähr man damit rechnet dass sich so die hälfte zwischen fünfzig und sechzig prozent.
Sich anstecken und vierzig prozent aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht so.
Gar nicht erwischt sozusagen.
Also es scheint bisher so die die zahlen zu sein also vierzig prozent erkrankten dann einfach nicht sei es weil sie nicht in kontakt kommen oder wie auch immer so.
Ja aber genau jetzt nochmal.
Nochmal zurück ja gesagt so seit seit ein paar tagen so bin ich beunruhigt und mit jedem tag halt zunehmend beunruhigt so weil ja.
Weil es vermutlich bereits zu spät
bei uns um sagen selbst wenn wir.
So also meine meine zahlen sehen so aus selbst wenn wir morgen oder am montag wenn wir wenn wir am montag jetzt alle schulen schließen würden alle müssen zuhause bleiben so also wenn wir quasi jetzt ab montag italien fahren.
Nicht nur italien.
Oder china oder wie auch immer.
Nee mittlerweile auch norwegen slowenien den.
Mit italien gut aber italien sozusagen hat glaube ich die drastische maßnahmen.
Schulen schluss.
Bisher ja ja die anderen sind erst mit schulen aber sagen ausgeh-verbote sagen in italien so wie ich das mitgekriegt habe dürfen leute nur noch unter bestimmten
bedingungen überhaupt das haus verlassen und
riskieren halt irgendwelche strafen wenn sie einfach so rumlaufen in bestimmten gegenden,
und also viel mehr geht fast nicht als zu sagen okay also,
alles was nicht was nicht überlebensnotwendig ist wird halt runtergefahren ich würde in berlin auch eigentlich müsste man in berlin wahrscheinlich auch den nahverkehr komplett einstellen so u-bahn s-bahn busse.
Sämtliche restaurants lokale und bars schließen so es ist wirklich nur noch supermärkte offen haben apotheken und ärzte und irgendwelche sonstigen not,
dienste aber das eigentlich ja so dann.
Fußball haben sie denn schon genommen wird schon kritisch.
Das ist ja und wenn sich man naja so aber selbst er selbst dann wenn das sozusagen ab montag passieren würde.
Wir müssen vielleicht mal ein datum sagen heute ist der zwölfte märz wir sind am donnerstag den zwölften märz hier zusammengekommen.
Also wenn es jetzt am montag den sechzehnten man jetzt,
man jetzt halt krass also das einführen würde glaube ich,
kommen wir trotzdem an die grenzen unseres gesundheitssystems.
Also ich ich und ich rechne aber nicht damit ja gut nächste woche wird irgendwas passieren aber wir sind eigentlich schon.
An dem an dem punkt meiner meinung nach dass wir unschöne bilder kriegen werden würden selbst wenn es montag losgeht wenn wir jetzt noch eine woche oder zwei wochen länger war,
so wie ich das ursprünglich also dachte ich so ja in zwei drei wochen wird hier das panik level dann so hoch sein dass es losgeht dann so
ja wir sind also wenn wir erst in drei wochen loslegen dann,
sind italienische verhältnisse so gar nichts dagegen.
Was was hier dann dann los ist ich meine wir haben ja wir haben zwanzigtausend intensiv betten aber davon sind.
Vielleicht viertausend wirklich nur für intensiv patienten frei so und.
Bei in italien haben wir gesehen dass in italien bei sieben achttausend erkrankten wobei es wahrscheinlich deutlich,
deutlich mehr waren aber ja zahlen sind halt schwer vergleichbar also italien hat's halt nicht geschafft so zu verhindern dass ja das gesundheitssystem.
Dem nicht mehr gewachsen ist und zwar innerhalb von zwei wochen.
So nachdem ich angefangen habe zu rechnen so hatte ich plötzlich das gefühl die situation.
Sieht schlimmer aus als das als man es im moment als als ich es eigentlich war haben wollte.
Also meine vermutung ist wir werden eigentlich nicht dran vorbei kommen einen kompletten look down zu haben.
Ich bin bei ihm gesagt das ist wiederum das ist das dilemma versucht man es langsam so eine exponentiell funktion entgleitet einem einfach zumal mit diesem die ladies ist wie wenn du keine ahnung einen einen,
weich gekochten spaghetti versuchst irgendwo in den schlüsselloch einzufädeln so ungefähr ja das was immer du.
Du tust und politik ist ja sowieso schon immer zu spät so was auch ganz in ordnung ist so politik meistens reagiert
halt auf auf dinge und ist jetzt nicht das ist das ist nun mal so.
Ist auch manchmal ganz gut dass sie etwas später reagiert weil sonst wird 's dann immer gleich hektisch.
Weil sonst also politik ist sowieso immer schwer zu spielen nicht immer unbedingt logik und sachliche erwägungen rein sondern es ist auch viel emotional und so.
Und ja vor dem hintergrund da politik wieder sowieso grundsätzlich zu spät ist es aber in dem fall halt.
Ein riesenproblem voll im hintergrund halt von exponenziell kurven weil meinte auch.
Jemand zu mir okay wenn wenn du es mit exponentiellem wachstum zu tun hast musst du eigentlich.
Immer agieren wenn du das gefühl hast dass es noch viel viel zu früh ist vor allen dingen eben mit diesen verzögerte exponentiellem wachstum.
Weil im moment verdoppelt sich die zahlen alle dreieinhalb tage etwa kann man halt wegen also jede woche,
so es ist ein faktor vier und,
wenn wir jetzt bei tausend sind sind wir in oder was ja wir sind jetzt fast bei sehr gut je nachdem welche zahlen man nimmt ob man die irgendwie fünf fünfzehnhundert irgendwas vom.
Nimmt von heute oder die zweitausend von von den von den zeitungen vom tagesspiegel glaube ich der betreibt da so ein ding diese die haben immer.
Die sind immer irgendwie schon viel voraus also jedenfalls ist das ding dass wir ja.
In zwei wochen die zehntausend die die italiener haben auch erreicht haben werden selbst wenn wir jetzt sofort.
Also du sprichst immer von infizierten zahl leute die den virus haben nicht tote.
Genau nein genau kumulativer genau kommunikativ leute die halt sagen nachweisbar den sich angesteckt haben die,
die gesamtzahl der der ansteckung ich meine einige davon sind schon wieder gesunde so die ersten aber das geht geht halt noch nicht so richtig.
Genau ich meine auf den sozialen medien geht's ja wie man sich vorstellen kann da wild zur sache was gerne rumgeht ist so ein kleines
gift was schön diesen überlassung moment zeigt und was man quasi erreichen kann dadurch dass man eben dinge verzögert beim time
man sieht quasi diese diese krankheitskosten flach sodass sie dann eben über die zeit von einem gesundheitssystem mit seiner kapazität eben auch,
gehandelt werden kann und wenn das eben nicht stattfindet dann bedeutet es ihnen automatisch mehr tote wie wir jetzt schon paar mal besprochen haben.
Ihr habt nur wieder so eine exponentiell kurve zu reiten oder abzuflachen mit einer,
zeitverzögerung ich würde mir wünschen dass es funktioniert aber alle erfahrung sagt mir
das wird nicht klappen so es hat auch also gut außer
es gibt einige wenige länder nämlich ausgerechnet die die damals von saß und mers so betroffen haben wie singapur zum beispiel oder taiwan.
Die halt wirklich gleich von anfang an
so die waren so die die haben nach der ersten meldung haben die sofort angefangen alle einreisende zu screen und zu kontrollieren und haben halt irgendwie auch ein super melde und reaktionszeit dem.
Aufgebaut und das hat das hat funktioniert so wir hatten halt,
ja nur was zehn fünfzehn jahre zeit so dass das.
Da ist nicht so dass kein notfallplan gibt es gibt ein und der bezieht sich sogar explizit auf so ein grippevirus also es ist damals nach saß auch aufgebaut worden muss halt bloß auch in kraft gesetzt werden das ist.
Ja ich habe also ich habe mir sowohl die notfallpläne vom bund als auch die von berlin,
angeguckt der von berlin war glaube ich von zweitausenddreizehn ungefähr da ist dann auch von antiviralen
impfstoffen für zwanzig prozent der bevölkerung die eingelagert worden sind die rede so,
ist aber jetzt so ich konnte aber nicht herausfinden ob es die noch gibt ob die vergammelt sind ob die.
Würde ja auch nichts helfen also es.
Ja vermutlich schon also.
Impfstoffe gibt's ja.
Nicht impfstoffe antivirale sagen antivirale medikamente nicht impfstoffe sondern sagen
medikamente die auch aus
bereich teilweise oder aus aus anderen oder auch bei bei grippe die halt sagen die die vermehrung der viren,
bremsen und verlangsamen und damit halt für einen günstigeren krankheitsverlauf sorgen.
Von davon waren halt irgendwie zwanzig zwanzig prozent der berliner bevölkerung wurde da wohl zeugs eingelagert laut diesen plan aber,
völlig unklar ob es die noch gibt und ob sie helfen würden,
ist man sich jetzt auch nicht sicher wobei sagen die erste tests wohl mit üblichen antiviralen mitteln ganz gut aussahen aber ja.
Mein vorgestern was mich vorgestern so beunruhigt hat war dass das plötzlich keine neuen zahlen veröffentlicht hatte,
und das ist natürlich auch so eine sache.
Also das robert koch institut.
Ja das robert-koch-institut was eigentlich so jetzt seit über einer woche eigentlich einen guten job macht und die ganzen zahlen konsolidiert die sind auch die wenn man beim,
gesundheitsministerium guckt sozusagen sind die die die offiziellen zahlen liefern also die sind sozusagen zuständig für die offiziellen zahlen so.
Es gibt zwei arten wieder die zahlen wohl hinkommen das eine ist irgendwie telefonisch dass die länder,
wer auch immer da anrufen und sagen wir haben jetzt irgendwie so und so viel neue bestätigte fälle es gibt aber auch ein elektronisches meldesystem.
Nur aus irgendwelchen gründen kommt nur der geringste teil der meldungen über das elektronische meldesystem.
Ein so wo man eigentlich auch denken müsste dass eigentlich alle stellen die das eigentlich mal melden müssten dass sie vielleicht internetzugang haben und leute die in der lage sind irgendwie dinge
einzugeben und eigentlich muss man ja denken auch dass elektronisches melden schneller geht aber was auch immer die da aufgesetzt haben
die elektronischen meldungen wie gesagt ein drittel ungefähr schaffen's einen rechner zu bedienen und das.
Was ist denn der rest fax oder was.
Ja ich weiß nicht fax telefon wie wie auch immer und deswegen ist die zahlen qualität ist halt auch nicht so der der hit weil
dann eben gesagt vorgestern waren auf einmal normalerweise haben sie mal morgens um acht und um fünfzehn uhr haben sie neue zahlen präsentiert so vorgestern war auf einmal,
irgendwie fünfzehn uhr vor also keine acht uhr zahlen keine fünfzehn uhr zahlen und um achtzehn uhr gab's immer noch keine zahlen ja dann haben sie so
mich gefragt was zum teufel also kriegen wir es jetzt nicht mal hin pünktlich die zahlen zu erfassen was
beunruhigend wäre oder
so gibt es irgendeinen grund warum jetzt die zahlen nicht genannt werden also beides war irgendwie beunruhigend ich war jetzt nicht der einzige der das verfolgt sondern konnte man sehen auf twitter und wie haben die leute dutzend weise so was ist mit den zahlen wo bleiben die zahlen irgendwann dann,
um halb zehn nachts so kam dann die zahl wirklich ja echt interessieren was so dahinter steckt.
Wie ist es so als erklärung naja die wollen jetzt eigentlich auf das elektronische meldesystem umstellen und deswegen gab es jetzt diese verzögerung aber ja also aber selbst diese zahlen übermittlung es nummer.
Ist nicht besonders vertrauen erweckt das ist und immer wie man so als als es hat oder so auch weiß oder wenn man irgendwelche technischen störungen hat so information ist das a und o und.
Um jetzt nicht gleich alle in panik auf die straße laufen zu lassen wenn sie dich hören.
Ich zitiere nochmal ganz kurz was das robert koch institut today now auf ihrer webseite sagt als nächstes mal.
Neunzehn also mit neunzehn ist ja die krankheit.
Das hier ist der offizielle name saß kopf zwei ist ist das virus was diese krankheit auslöst,
und diese krankheit wurde aber jetzt quasi von der who von der weltgesundheitsorganisation zur pandemien erklärt gestern am elften dritten.
Weiß nicht ganz genau was das triggert aber es ist auf jeden fall schon mal ein statement.
Eigentlich waren die schwelle werte für das triggern waren schon glaube ich also es gibt gibt da irgendwelche in sohn zu viel ländern so und so viel gesamt und ich hatte nur gehört dass das eigentlich schon,
länger überschritten war und sie aber aus irgendwelchen gründen gewartet haben.
Haben wir noch zeit.
Was sagt das genau was.
Das sagt die gefährdung für die gesundheit der bevölkerung in deutschland wird derzeit insgesamt als mäßig eingeschätzt.
Die gefährdung diese gefährdung der variiert aber von region zu regionen ist besonders betroffenen gebieten hoch,
die wahrscheinlichkeit für schwere krankheitsverlauf nimmt mit zunehmenden alter und bestehenden vorerkrankungen zu die belastung des gesundheitswesen hängt maßgeblich von der regionalen verbreitung der infektionen fahrenden kapazitäten und den eingeleiteten gegenmaßnahmen
ab und kann örtlich sehr hoch sein diese einschätzung kann sich kurzfristig durch neue erkenntnisse ändern ja.
Die aktuelle risikobewertung falls sein ich weiß nicht was da ein zukunftsmodell vorausgesagt hat für den zwölften dritten projektion gemacht.
Ja meine allererste exponentielle wie gesagt liegt halt deutlich drüber mit zweitausend siebenhundertvierundsiebzig für heute genau.
Für heute ja das bin ich.
So nein nein wir sind.
Tausendfünfhundert fünfhundertsiebenundsechzig.
Ja genau heute ist der zwölfte her,
also aber das hatte ich ja eingangs schon gesagt dass ich schon das wachstum verlangsamt weil also solange der panik faktor also man kann das ganz gut simulieren ich hatte dann
ich hatte dann noch mal bessere simulationen mit sagen einem abnehmenden also mit einem leicht abnehmendem ex von
exponenten mit einem panik faktor und der.
Und meine korrigierte weil ich finde wenn die gerade nicht aber ja also es,
scheint im moment langsamer zu
wachsen als mit einem konstanten exponenten trotzdem alle dreieinhalb tage ungefähr verdopplung und das problem ist dass halt die zahlen halt sehr voraussicht sind dass halt der zeitraum wann die gemeldet werden dass halt oft dann
an einem tag wenig zahlen kommen und dann am nächsten tag plötzlich du ein riesensprung hast weil irgendwie am vortag ist zu einer milde verzögerung.
Faxt kam nicht.
Kommen ist es faxt kam nicht durch oder weiß der geier und wenn du dir auch anguckst,
und achso und des zählt nur fälle die offiziell von einem labor bestätigt,
geworden so guckst du dir dagegen was er sich die die zahlen beim tagesspiegel an.
So sind wir wahrscheinlich.
Weil wir die zahlen nicht aus dem labor kommen wo kommen sie dann her.
Das sind dann wiederum auch zahlen sankt offizielle verlautbarungen der bundesländer also es ist jetzt nicht dass sie sich das irgendwie sich die
sich der tagesspiegel des aus dem hintern zieht aber das sind also auch offizielle zahlen das ist halt auch das problem wenn du halt in die wikipedia reinguckst so
findest du halt auch je nachdem wo du guckst,
an verschiedenen stellen der seite findest du einmal die offiziellen zahlen aber sagen dann die offizielle zahl wiederum aber warte mal wo.
Ich gucke grade mal wo die wo die seite ist da sind wir schon über zweitausend also bei der und die zählt auch permanent also da wird sagen jede neue meldung wird dort mit.
Wird dort sofort.
Sofort eingestellt und angezeigt und auch sagen regional und dann formulieren die das automatisch auf was.
Gut am ende ist egal weil man weiß beide zahlen sind falsch weil es wird es gibt mit sicherheit weiß man aus china jetzt deutlich mehr infizierte
als natürlich erfasst werden aber so für die vorhersage ist es halt relativ egal.
Hauptsache man hat irgendwie konstante datenqualität sowas aber.
Ja gut die chinesen hatten damit auch ihre probleme aber wir scheinen da jetzt auch nicht so super viel besser zu sein.
So jetzt ist die frage wie gehen wir damit um oder wie kann die gesellschaft damit überhaupt umgehen.
Vielleicht mal.
Nochmal einen blick auf andere auswirkungen die sich ja auch noch abgezeichnet haben abgesehen jetzt von diesem rhein lok down
der ist natürlich für die italienische wirtschaft und damit natürlich auch für die gesamte gesellschaft und damit natürlich auch für sehr viele leute die,
sag mal jetzt nicht so einen job haben der sie auch mal locker zwischendurch wenn nichts los ist drei monate am leben erhält ist das natürlich ein riesen problem.
Grundsätzlich haben wir glaube ich in europa noch den vorteil dass man hier.
Verschiedene abstufungen und geschmacksrichtungen weitgehend eigentlich überall.
Irgendwas von passabel bis ok streckenweise auch mal gute gesundheitssysteme hat die das jetzt eben mehr oder weniger gut abfedern können.
Aber es ist natürlich eine belastung weil der ganz normale ablauf wird natürlich massiv gestört und das merkt man jetzt auch schon also jetzt wo wir hier nur so auf.
Halber kraftfahren also was ist jetzt passiert eigentlich sind nur großveranstaltungen abgesagt worden so bis zu tausend leute aber auch das hat ja schon enorme implikationen messen finden nicht statt,
ja das ist gerade für den standort wie berlin.
Signifikanten also berlin ist der was viele nicht wissen zweitgrößte konferenz standort europas.
Nirgendwo finden so viele sachen statt mit der ausnahme von wien das nämlich platz eins.
Das heißt davon lebt die stadt auch und das ist natürlich nicht nicht mehr und wie es derzeit aussieht was war die ansage bis zum ende der osterfest.
Womit ja im prinzip auch die osterferien vermute.
Wann war das nochmal in den osterferien in.
Neunzehnter april.
Neunzehnter april es wäre also sechs wochen knapp fünf wochen jetzt ungefähr.
Also fünf wochen könnte gehen wenn wir sozusagen in einer woche die reißleine ziehen.
Könnte gehen im sinne von wenn jetzt lok down gemacht wird schulen geschlossen werden wir werden den uns einfach nur noch in unserem stadtteil rumtreiben wenn überhaupt dass wir das,
soweit im griff bekommen dass wir keine weiteren ansteigen der fallzahlen haben.
Immerhin ein ding,
das habe ich noch nicht also das geht bei mir im kopf noch nicht so richtig zusammen oder weiß ich noch nicht was was passieren wird da wird das werden wir allerdings an china auch sehen
nämlich gut china hat es jetzt geschafft den den virus den den anstieg zu stoppen aber,
dort sind nach wie vor noch die maßnahmen überwiegend in kraft sie beginnen jetzt erst damit die zu lockern gerade.
So und,
wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht ich meine hier auch der trosten heißt der glaube ich der chef physiologe oder auf die kanzlerin sagte jetzt ja man rechnet damit dass fünfzig bis sechzig prozent wie gesagt über kurz oder lang erkranken,
werden china hat ja jetzt bei achtzigtausend irgendwo achtundachtzigtausend glaube ich gestoppt.
Aber es gibt dann ungefähr jetzt noch eine milliarde chinesen von denen irgendwie eigentlich dann auch mal im laufe der zeit fünfhundert millionen doch jetzt potenziell anstecken können so.
Wie geht das jetzt weiter in in china so fangen die jetzt an zu lockern so ist es jetzt hat es sich jetzt totgelaufen oder wird in dem moment wo das ganze gelockert wird,
fahren wir dann komplett die wiederholung und haben wir dann jetzt sagen fahren wir dann jedes mal so für
hunderttausend so pro hunderttausend infizierte ungefähr machen wir dann wieder einen shutdown für acht wochen und dann die nächsten hunderttausend jemand da kann man die nächsten zweihundert jahre
mit weitermachen.
Kurze ich meine bis dahin hofft natürlich die medizin auch ein entsprechendes imk serum gefunden zu haben also von daher machen sich glaube ich viele derzeit noch so die hoffnung dass das ganze so anderthalb jahre zwei maximal zu tragen sein muss aber du hast natürlich recht
nur weil jetzt die fallzahlen sinken heißt es ja noch nicht dass der virus aus der welt ist so zumal er sich ja eben gerade auch noch in anderen bereichen der welt verteilt wo es,
alles noch viel krassere auswirkungen haben kann also so afrika,
auch da ist der virus schon angekommen wird's nicht so gut aussehen mit dem gesundheitssystem aufwenden,
dort vielleicht auch nicht so eine hohe dichte
überall vorliegt klar also wenn es sowas wie in nigeria oder sowas befallen sein würde dann dürfte das dann auch krasse auswirkungen.
Also im im prinzip will das aber bedeuten dass wir halt bis.
Einen impfstoff großflächig verfügbar sind wir wahrscheinlich mit wiederholten shutdown bis zu tun
haben werden oder sich überhaupt und da kommen wir jetzt ja auch zu dem zu dem punkt wie
man jetzt das eigene verhalten ändert wie leute sich anders verhalten wir haben uns zum beispiel als ich heute hierher gekommen bin haben wir
ohne darüber zu reden nicht irgendwie die hände geschüttelt oder uns nicht irgendwie ja keine hacks so und ja.
Du bist jetzt standard.
Ist jetzt ist jetzt standard gerade und.
Ich bin auch froh dass mein podcast ist hier so zwei meter distanz zwischen.
Sind fast drei meter glaube ich und ich meine ich hatte tatsächlich auch dann schon oft überlegt eigentlich,
ist es ganz gut wenn wenn sowieso die wahrscheinlichkeit bei fünfzig prozent liegt,
über sechzig prozent oder sich sowieso fast alle anstecken ist natürlich gut wenn man sich so früh wie möglich ansteckt dann kann man erstens die quarantänezeit nutzen die kommen wird.
Was lustiges zu machen.
Naja dann hat man's halt hinter sich und natürlich möglichst sagen bevor jetzt das chaos los bricht weil.
Noch betten freier.
Im moment hat man noch ganz gute chancen so wenn man jetzt komplikationen
hat aber das kann in zwei drei wochen kann es sein dass einfach schlichtweg ja nicht mehr genug intensivbetten oder andere dinge da sind so dass es eigentlich ja,
ja wenn man sich früh infiziert sage er einen glücksfall ist nicht mein.
Nicht dass ich jetzt irgendwelche keine ahnung für für masern parties oder so den weil am ende.
Auf so eine idee ist auch schon jemand gekommen natürlich ja ich.
Wir müssen aufpassen dass wir hier nicht zu sehr springen.
Bevor wir vielleicht mal auf mal so den look da auch nochmal so durchspielen und und und was das so mit uns und mit der gesellschaft so.
Man hat ja auch so konkrete psychologische auswirkungen etcetera vielleicht erst nochmal so die.
Aus der abteilung aktuell sichtbare unmittelbare auswirkungen die jetzt schon da sind.
Wirtschaft und vor allem halt das vertrauen da drin also gerade in den usa geht es gerade richtig rund auch die haben steigende zahlen,
das land scheint gerade keinerlei.
Brauchbare führung zu haben trump hat ja gleich zu beginn seiner amtszeit den noch von obama oder busch eingesetzten pandemien rat aufgelöst braucht man ja nicht.
Hat also jetzt kein und überhaupt ist diese ganze regierung ja nicht gerade mit experten gesegnet zu was auch immer.
Einzige expertise der erzielt ist so wie kann man die anna macht bleiben und wie kann man mehr geld verdienen so.
Ja gut in der praxis also es ist nicht alles so schlimm dort.
Na ja gut aber sie haben auf jeden fall auch viel zeit verloren sie haben das komplett ignoriert am anfang war das irgendwie die chinesische gefahr jetzt haben sie irgendwie ein einreiseverbot erhoben gegenüber europa aber mit der ausnahme von,
was auch immer,
da jetzt weniger infektiös machen sollte aber auch das ist ganz klar ihre geleitete politik an der stelle.
Und und amerikaner betrifft es auch nicht also amerikaner dürfen auch von europa aus ein reisen genau.
Nur ausländer sozusagen ist ein ausländer virus ach ja.
So das heißt sie werden sehr schnell das problem haben oder haben es im prinzip jetzt schon aber es wird sich jetzt dort auch in den nächsten paar wochen verschärfen und zwar glaube ich das vor allem deshalb weil.
Sie natürlich diese spezifische problem haben mit dem gesundheitssystem was den namen nicht verdient da gab es ja schon ein paar wirklich nice fälle wo jemand sich auf verdacht.
Hat mal testen lassen irgendwohin gegangen ist so hier ich war in kontakt mit leuten die das hatten weil glaube ich so der hintergrund so und danach gibt es und dann.
Der test konnte dann ja genau und dann konnte der test nicht durchgeführt werden.
Aber schon für dieses nicht durchführen des tests also die zeit die das auch in anspruch genommen habe wurde dann gleich eine rechnung von über zehntausend dollar gestellt andere fälle kenne ich wohl.
Normale tests die durchgeführt wurden irgendwie auch mehrere tausend dollar so.
Und jetzt muss man halt nochmal die realitäten us a sich rauskam das sollte einfach
nicht so ein single-player system ist wie bei uns dass die leute halt im allerbesten fall eine arsch teure mit hohen
selbstbeteiligung ausgestatteten
krankenversicherung haben wenn sie gerade mal glück haben in einem job wo das irgendwie über die firma geregelt ist das ist so der der idealzustand und den haben nur sehr wenige das heißt sehr viele leute werden einfach nicht zum arzt gehen,
werden nicht als fall gezählt werden einfach weil sie sich das nicht leisten können.
Und dann hast du im prinzip genauso eine italien situation in einem land.
Was noch schwerer auf anweisung des staates zur freiheitseinschränkung reagieren wird das ist eine einschätzung an der stelle.
Wobei interessanterweise also wer jetzt wieder nur an die zahlen guckt wieviel also intensivbetten was beispielsweise in den usa gibt dann sind es rund fünfundneunzigtausend.
So gegenüber deutschland mit zwanzigtausend intensiv betten so und auf die bevölkerung wiederum runtergerechnet heißt es dass die amerikaner.
Hören sogar mehr pro also pro kopf mehr intensivbetten haben als deutschland was wiederum zumindest bei ich weiß jetzt nicht,
bei intensivbetten aber zumindest sagen bei krankenhausbetten überhaupt liegt deutschland europa weit vorne so.
Kann aber nur keine zahlen in usa.
Na ja gut irgendjemand wird schon für die assis fünfundneunzigtausend dinger intensiv diese eis sind halt da und machen sich sicherlich auch also irgendjemand musste für die einrichtung und den betrieb.
Sind halt so teuer dass wir nochmal eine eine woche drin liegt dass ich das auch gleich gelohnt hat fürs jahr.
Okay gut.
Ich meine gut okay aber muss sie sehen im amerikanischen gesundheitssystem ich glaube sagen sind die gesundheitskosten liegen bei fünfzehnhundert dollar pro kopf pro
monat so das heißt es also man sollte es amerikanische gesundheitssystem nicht unterschätzen so die haben da verdammt viel kohle drin.
Ich will das auch nicht unterschätzen aber ich,
ich bin auf jeden fall extrem skeptisch was gerade die fähigkeit der us-regierung betrifft mit so einer krise professionell umzugehen man sieht man ja schon trumps im wesentlichen damit beschäftigt irgendwie unwahrheiten zu verbreiten und irgendwie
kümmert sich eigentlich nur dadrum dass er da gut aussieht und das war's dann so und hat irgendwie eine unkomplizierte erste riege und die potenziell,
kompetente zweite riege wie in so vielen anderen bereichen seines government sind halt schon längst gefeuert arbeiten woanders weil sie kein bock auf den scheiß haben.
Auf der anderen seite hast du die merkels rede angehört oder gelesen jetzt vor von gestern oder vorgestern war das glaube ich.
Auszügen.
Und ich hab irgendwie.
Also inhalte habe ich vermisst in der in der rede da war außer dass sie irgendwie ein paar sachen von dem trosten des dass wir wir werden alle krank werden und müssen irgendwie.
Das beste hoffen und sind aber gut eigentlich ganz okay vorbereitet aber dann doch wieder also es wird schwierig werden aber wir werden das schon irgendwie also.
Ja gut aber das ist ja eine andere dimension also man sich da hinstellt und sagt manche leute sprechen von diesen zahlen ich denke es ist weniger und das problem wird nächste woche schon wieder weg sein.
Das ist das ist natürlich absolut fahrlässig auf der anderen seite sagen,
wenn du dir dann anguckst ja in anderen ländern oder in singapur so wird wird immer wieder diese eine rede zitiert von dem politiker der halt ganz klar einfach mal,
gesagt hat so ist es so sieht's aus das müssen wir tun und ja.
Und und fertig also da war einfach auch eine eine klarheit und informiert heit drin und was ich mir gewünscht hätte oder sag mal so wenn ich jetzt kanzler wäre ich,
hätte mich wahrscheinlich irgendwann also wenn ich mich zu wort gemeldet hätte hätte ich hätte ich dann gesagt so
ja das und das wird jetzt passieren und muss jetzt getan werden und also,
jetzt so vom vom impact her so war das irgendwie mehr so wie mutti sagt und fahr bitte vorsichtig.
Pass auf dich auf.
Passt auf passt auf euch auf und ich meine,
hat vielleicht zumindest hat zwar kein schaden angerichtet würde ich sagen aber hat jetzt auch also,
irgendwie aber auch jetzt nicht unbedingt einen positiven beitrag dazu geleistet weil natürlich klar,
wollen ich wollte nicht beunruhigen vermutlich auch also nicht zu viel panik machen weil dann schadet das ja der wirtschaft und die leute haben angst die leute sollen ja keine angst haben.
Aber,
also ich kenne leute die mittlerweile ihre kinder von sich aus aus den schulen rausnehmen die die nicht mehr zur schule schicken weil die das einfach für unverantwortlich erhalten und ja das wird jetzt und ich glaube das wird jetzt ganz ganz schnell umkippen und um
umschlagen.
Ich wollte eigentlich auf die wirtschaft auswirkungen rausholen der dow jones dow jones,
gut da kann man jetzt was drauf geben kann man auch was nicht drauf geben,
gibt da generell eigentlich nicht so viel drauf aber es ist halt schon krass wenn er eben so sehr in keller geht und das wird auf jeden fall,
zu einer allgemeinen schwächung beitrag also nicht nur in den usa sondern halt auch in deutschland macht es jetzt auch gemerkt so.
Et cetera das zieht jetzt glaube ich alles mittlerweile bitcoin-preis ist wieder gefallen.
Weil das krasseste fand ich ja den ölpreis ich weiß nicht ob du dir die ölpreis statistik mal angeguckt.
Ja aber das hat glaube ich andere gründe das ist weil die saudis halt gerade wieder mittiges öl raushauen ohne ende und das geht eigentlich im wesentlichen mehr um ihren konflikt den sie mit russland haben.
Ja ja naja aber das hat natürlich jetzt sagen die krise hat natürlich,
angefangen auf den ölpreis zu drücken und dann hat sich das nochmal und ich glaube der ist um über fünfzig prozent gefallen in den letzten monaten oder um sechzig prozent also im dezember
weil ich meine ich war ja noch irgendwo bei fast achtzig neunzig und jetzt sind wir was bei fünf bei dreißig bis vierzig also ich habe jetzt die zahlen nicht genau im kopf kommt mama.
Gucken aber das das war sagen das hat mich richtig umgehauen so dass das so ja aber natürlich ja.
Aktien gehen in keller die frage ist was das jetzt für die immobilienpreise.
Natürlich auch wiederum bedeutet die werden die leute jetzt alle in immobilien gehen oder in,
deutsche staatsanleihen werden jetzt gerade überall empfohlen so für leute die international die halt irgendwie aus den aktien rausgehen weil klar wenn die aktie natürlich so runtergehen.
Muss das geld irgendwo anders hin und ja.
Zum ölpreis also der hat es im letzten jahr ist er so um die fünfzig dollar rum jahrhundert und ist anfang.
Diesen.
Jahres schnell nach unten gestürzt so und das sind zwei stufen und jetzt aber schon zweiundvierzig prozent minus im vergleich zum jahres.
In den letzten tagen daraus lese man was man will.
Ok also ich hab dezember war irgendwie dreiundsechzig und.
Genau das nochmal ganz kurz hoch gehüpft.
Ja okay und jetzt ist er hat er sich ein bisschen wieder erholt aber der war genau er war dann auf zweiunddreißig oder so runter also tatsächlich von von dezember bis heute also in vier monaten habt ihr ja,
quasi.
Kurz halbiert und jetzt dabei zweiundvierzig prozent minus.
Und naja gut das ist das wäre natürlich auch noch riesenprobleme.
Auch für die usa natürlich geben weil dort die ganzen fracking leute.
Das ist auch der grund warum das gemacht wird ich meine deswegen machen die saudis das die wollen halt diese unabhängigkeit der usa
möglichst unterbinden also sicherlich nicht der einzige grund den sie da haben aber es einer der gründe der andere ist dass sich halt diese niedrigen preise auch leisten können und ihre ganzen mitbewerber iranische darauf ausland
eben nicht so ohne weiteres die machen dann halt einfach nicht mehr genug kohle und saudi-arabien sitzt da entsprechend auf den,
finanziellen reserven um sowas auch locker mal ein paar jahre durchzuziehen geht auch nicht alles ewig und so weiter ist auch konkretes geld was sie machen aber es hat eine wette die sie da,
an den start gebracht haben und da bleiben sie erstmal hart und das ist natürlich dann so ein ding ne gut trump hält natürlich eine aktuelle situation gerade nichts besseres ein als dann sozusagen so große not.
Anstatt jetzt hier mal irgendwie geld aufzulegen um leuten,
geld zu bezahlen damit sie wenn sie krank sind zuhause bleiben und nicht alle anderen anstecken so sowas rauszuholen kann man jetzt irgendwie mit einem rettungs- und steuersenkungen plan für energieunternehmen damit die irgendwie diesen niedrigen ölpreis.
Denk doch auch mal einer an diese denk doch mal einer an diese armen energieunternehmen.
Na gut soviel zur wirtschaft ist auf jeden fall etwas was man mal im auge haben sollte.
So reden wir doch mal ein wenig.
Über was so kommen könnte weil meine klingt so ein bisschen klingt so ein bisschen merkwürdig aber ich finde das ja auch ganz interessant also krise hat man ja nicht so oft.
Und die auswirkung davon haben wir auch teilweise in china schon gesehen dieses schöne bild mit der stickoxid belastung.
Stickoxid hier ja.
Ja
vorher große industrieregion peking vor allem aber halt auch so shanghai diese ganzen hotspots.
Alles unter einer dicken glocke und kaum sind die fabrik mal so ein bisschen runtergefahren gibt's auf einmal wieder frische luft das hatten die wahrscheinlich schon lange nicht mehr.
Und wahrscheinlich der ausstoß an klimagase wird sich global wahrscheinlich.
Erheblich reduzieren durch die auswirkung vor allem im flugverkehr,
ich glaube der lufthansa hat schon mal so sechzig prozent aller strecken die jetzt gerade nicht mehr bedient werden ich glaube die ganze a dreihundertachtzig flotte ist komplett gegrundet da läuft gar nichts mehr wegen der langstrecken die er da normalerweise bedient werden vor allem eben nach china.
Nicht nur aber viele eben diese region.
Aber es ist natürlich auch grundsätzlich die frage was macht das sozusagen mit der gesellschaft also wie sind wir denn da so psychologisch eigentlich,
aufgestellt gerade deutschland hat ja nun eine lange lange phase von uns geht's irgendwie gut was kümmert uns das elend der welt so mir nichts mit zu tun.
Es gibt ja zu jedem zeitpunkt eigentlich immer genug elend aber es ist halt sehr ungleich verteilt was siehst oder so.
Ja erstmal vielleicht wir können vielleicht noch mal weitermachen mit möglichen positiven auswirkungen so ich meine angefangen bei was ganz einfachen dass ich vielleicht ein bisschen das bewusstsein von.
Einigen arbeitgebern ändert die
sagen dass man halt die leute halt normalerweise immer mit erkältungen oder grippe oder weiß ich nicht was zur arbeit kommen und dann irgendwie die halbe firma verseuchen jetzt unabhängig mal von,
corona so fand ich.
Das war glaube ich in berlin tatsächlich auch der erste fall wo wo die alle zwei wochen lang husten irgendwie noch am arbeitsplatz saß und dann.
Ja ja ja also es ist nicht nicht alle firmen nicht in allen firmen ist es so aber es gibt halt viele firmen wo das ist und speziell in den usa ist natürlich nochmal krass schlimmer gerade in den niedriglohn
dinge an der ist auch nichts mit lot fortgezahlt lang und so aber generell also,
wer ein positives ding wenn sich vielleicht mal dass das bewusstsein dahingehend ändert dass man leute die gerade an einer akuten,
atemwegs infektion leiden egal ob's jetzt irgendwie der der allgemeine schnupfen oder die grippe oder irgendwas anderes ist,
dass man sagen da einfach generell so,
sensibler wird mit mit umgehen dass wir sagen eine positive wirkung ein,
learning ein anderes ding ist das vielleicht ein allgemeines umdenken stattfindet dass man man wer mehr gesehen dass wirtschaft und.
Alles infrastruktur irgendwie alles sankt kostenlos optimiert wurde und auf kante.
Genäht ist dass man da vielleicht auch das ganze thema resilienz und so und ein bisschen mehr kapazitäten für sowas schafft und,
eventuell ist es auch der notwendige warnschuss den wir gerade brauchen weil.
So korona ist zwar schlimm aber wir haben insofern noch glück im unglück das sagen die zahl der leute die daran sterben,
relativ gering ist im vergleich jetzt zu jetzt märz oder oder saß wo man halt modalität von dreißig prozent teilweise hatte das.
Nur eben nicht so eine hohe inflationsrate.
Noch nicht so aber jetzt stellt man sich vor ich meine es gibt viele leute die seit langem so von einer
pandemien warnen und jetzt stelle man sich vor sowas wie corona nur das halt ein drittel der leute dran,
sterben und nicht irgendwie ein oder fünf prozent so das ist jetzt auch nicht.
Nicht nicht ausgeschlossen und wie man jetzt gesehen hat dass die länder die damals betroffen waren von saß und mers misst die kleineren es geschafft haben
strukturen und mechanismen aufzubauen
um jetzt wesentlich besser mit klarzukommen sowie singapur und taiwan und und und andere ja.
Das heißt dass man vielleicht wieder ein bisschen langfristiger denken wird oder ein bisschen mehr vorsorge betreiben wird und.
In den usa wird man sehen je nachdem wie sich da entwickelt dass man vielleicht auch
dortmund gewisses umdenken stattfinden wird aber muss man mal
abwarten zumal mal sehen was so jetzt umgang mit kranken krankenversicherten lohnvorzahlung und und so weiter an,
geht und das gesamte gesundheitssystem also da zumindest eine hoffnung je nachdem wie es verläuft dass es,
sozusagen alles im im nachgang zumindest wir dann besser aufgestellt,
sind in vielerlei hinsicht und ja uns dann vielleicht das große sterben bei der nächsten pandemien dadurch erspart bleibt dass wir halt jetzt sowas wie.
Corona durchmachen.
Ein weiterer begünstigende faktor ist ja auch dass es halt.
Vor allem alte leute zu treffen scheint.
Der trosten hat das irgendwie ausgedrückt mit einer kurve und keine.
Also typischerweise hat man so kurven so die ganz schwachen sind gefährdet bei bestimmten erkrankungen norovirus etcetera und die die halt sowieso schon schwach sind gegen ende ihres lebens.
Richtig unangenehm wird's wenn's eine weg kurve wird wenn dann halt sozusagen auch noch in der mitte.
Ein problem auftritt was so typischerweise so noro virus und sowas mit sich bringt das heißt das sind die leute die familien haben also die kinder haben die quasi wo die kids dann immer schön die viren.
Der kita oder aus der schule mitbringen und dann familien an der stelle auch nochmal stärker betroffen sind
wobei dann eben die vierzig fünfzig jährigen fraktion deren potenziell ihre kinder wenn sie welche hatten schon aus dem haus haben,
dann eben nicht so betroffen sind und dann erst wieder.
Bei den sechzig bis siebzig und eltern älteren dann zu neuen problemen führt.
Ja was kann das jetzt mit uns machen also was was ist ja auch noch zeigt.
Und auch da muss man dann glaube ich auch jeden fall wieder neu bewerten von einer pandemien.
Wie schnell kann sich das halt verbreiten und was wir natürlich jetzt auch sehen ist,
so eine ganz konkrete auswirkung der globalisierung in allen ebenen einerseits was natürlich diese reise tätigkeit tourismus et cetera betrifft den tourismus wird da jetzt auch extrem leiden.
Aber natürlich auch diese ganze business verflechtung die man hat die ganzen abhängigkeiten voneinander dass was ich so das meiste wird halt in china produziert,
wenn china nicht mehr produziert dann gibt's halt irgendwie kinder teile gibt es keinen
kram kein plastik-stückchen hier wasser nicht alles gemacht wird macht man sich glaube ich manchmal gar nicht so richtig klar wieviel mittlerweile eigentlich aus diesem
chinesisch asiatischen raum kommen was hier einfach für den betrieb einer wirtschaft absolut erforderlich ist schlecht weil wir eben angefangen haben.
Bestimmte sachen einfach gar nicht mehr zu produzieren.
So und wenn das dann diese quelle daneben wegfällt dann steht man da mit mit mit mit gar nix also die annahme dass das der rest der welt schon immer irgendwie liefern würde sowas wird ja hier auch ein opfer.
Mein da ist dann zumindest also was bei lebensmitteln angeht deutschland hat ja noch einen,
selbstversorgung von neunzig prozent wissen auch die wenigsten ich meine das war mal in den neunziger jahren waren wir noch bei neunundneunzig prozent bei nahrungsmitteln.
Neunzigerjahren aha.
Also es ist jetzt auf neunzig prozent runter gegangen aber sagen ist
immer noch immer in deutschland ist europas größter agrarproduzenten gut werde ich auch was mit der fläche zu tun aber insofern also verhungern werden wir zumindest nicht
so wie es aussieht so aber
natürlich in ganz vielen bereichen wird jetzt abzuwarten sein ob es dann tatsächlich die lieferketten,
irgendwie zusammen brechen noch sieht es nicht,
danach aus aber ja ausgeschlossen ist ist natürlich erstmal auch nicht und vor allen dingen.
Wenn dann halt natürlich jede menge firmenpleiten machen die fehlen dann natürlich auch,
und das wird sicherlich eine pleite welle geben,
weltweit dadurch mein tourismus hattest du schon gesagt ich glaube tourismus ist weltweit der größte wirtschaftsfaktor,
tatsächlich also tourismussektor ist
für sich genommen glaube ich mit das nicht zehn oder zwanzig prozent in der in der gegend sagen der größte lang wirtschaftssektoren global gesehen überhaupt und.
Da
Wird natürlich jetzt vielen leuten einfach das geld fehlen aber natürlich auch in anderen bereichen in meinen gastronomie.
Das geld fehlen um jetzt in urlaub zu fahren.
Nee das geld sozusagen auf bald bei den hotels auf der einnahmeseite bei den bei den hotels,
und und so und aber auch frag mich wie die ganzen restaurants und kneipen in berlin zum beispiel durchhalten wollen ich war samstag das letzte mal aus so und,
da waren schon in vielen läden was bemerkenswert leer aber nicht hin,
allen also aber noch also vor allem in der ständigen vertretung da bin ich dann auch vorbeigekommen aus ausgerechnet so da war es so rammelvoll,
so da war party halli galli also wenn da ein infizierten dabei gewesen ist am samstag in der ständigen vertretung werden's gleich fünfzig oder hundert neue fälle gewesen.
Muss man noch dazu sagen ständige vertretung ist so ein relativ bekanntes,
restaurant im bundesvision also relativ nah dran am bundestag an der bundespressekonferenz etcetera untertreiben sich halt sehr viele.
Und,
ständig ja mittlerweile als wohl ein bisschen nachgelassen weil das so so geworden ist hat auch jetzt irgendwie den besitzer gewechselt und so aber
es ist außerdem auch die ständige vertretung des rheinlandes in berlin
so wobei es mittlerweile ist auch in anderen städten gibt dass sie haben eine franchise rausgemacht wohl,
aber ja und gerade natürlich in nordrhein-westfalen als hochrisiko gebiet keine ahnung wie viele leute da jetzt irgendwie gekommen sind um kölsch oder alt oder so
zu trinken also das das fand ich schon so ein bisschen da hätte ich mich nicht wohl gefühlt in dem laden während in dem restaurant in dem ich war,
war nur zehn prozent der tische besetzt so wir saßen.
Weiß ich nicht zehn meter vom nächsten tisch entfernt und da fühlte man sich denn.
Einigermaßen sicher so aber wenn das.
Die deutsche bahn hat auch schon vierzig prozent weniger fahrten registriert so nach ihren zählungen geht davon aus dass ich das noch weiter reduzieren wird
dem der öffentliche nahverkehr da wird's natürlich knifflig ne also
in dieser ganzen debatte in den letzten tagen mit sollen sollen wir denn das jetzt überhaupt einleiten es hat sich ja vor allem erstmal viel über den fußball festgemacht weil die saison ist ja noch voll am rennen dann
das sind jetzt die ersten geisterspiele wie das so schön heißt abgegeben gehalten worden um einfach,
hier zu sagen so ja ist jetzt nicht so gut wenn sich so viele leute permanent treffen,
und da kann man ja auch gleich so eine seiten debatte mit auf mit naja wenn man jetzt hier fußballspiele verbietet dann müsste man ja auch einen öffentlichen nahverkehr einschränken,
was jetzt durchaus eine option ist nur in dem moment wo du das dann eben machst stirbt natürlich dann auch automatisch noch sehr viel mehr weil dann kommt auch keiner mehr zur arbeit dann
können die firmen nicht mehr weiterarbeiten müssen relativ schnell eigentlich im betrieb einstellen gerade in so einer stadt wie berlin wo sich das ja auch nicht nur in berlin so ja also leute können sich das
leben in der mitte in der nähe des arbeitsplatzes eigentlich gar nicht leisten wohnen weiter weg also ohne öffentlichen nahverkehr läuft eigentlich dann überhaupt nichts mehr.
Ich habe irgendwie busfahrer verkaufen jetzt keine fahrkarten mehr aus gründen des infektionsschutz es und die leute sollen hinten einsteigen in den bus.
Jetzt wieder hinten.
Und es berghain hat irgendwie zugemacht bis glaube ich irgendwie april oder so wahrscheinlich viele andere clubs werden wahrscheinlich einfach folgen so selbst wenn's jetzt nicht die auflage gibt kann ich mir vorstellen dass ganz viele läden
einfach zu machen werden weil es.
Weil einfach keine leute mehr kommen.
Weil einfach die leute nicht kommen und das billiger ist den laden einfach ganz zuzumachen dann.
Als jetzt irgendwie ja dein personal zu bezahlen und so also es wird.
Wahrscheinlich von alleine kommen obwohl bisher dieser samstag war noch nicht viel sichtbar außer dass halt das allgemein lehrer war.
Na gut aber wir befinden uns jetzt glaube ich auch gerade in den in den tagen wo die sache einfach beschleunigung bekommen von daher ist unser timing vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja was sonst noch so ansonsten hatte ich war aber eher das gefühl zwischenzeitlich als wenn
corona grundsätzlich eher das schlechte in den menschen
hervor kehrt also diese berichte von wo die leute auf der kinderkrebsstation desinfektionsmittel geklaut haben so ja ja
und und und und masken und angeblich irgendwie ein ganzer lkw von der mit mit atemschutz masken für die charité wurde wohl leergeräumt und
so
also solche sachen oder dann auch fand ich gut mittlerweile sich das ein bisschen anders aber sozusagen die erste welle der hamster käufe so fand ich jetzt auch
eine
frau irgendwie wohl die die dann irgendwie die letzten zehn flaschen desinfektionsmittel dann mitgenommen hat so das ist dann auch so das treibt bei mir dann schon so ein bisschen den hass hoch weil
erstens kann man auch seife wunderbar nehmen und zweitens finde ich es einfach ich meine ja.
Man kann nicht nur seife wunderbar nehmen sondern tatsächlich ist es sogar so dass konkret bei diesem virus seife die beste waffe ist.
Denn da habe ich ein schönes video zugesehen mal gucken ob ich das noch verlinkt bekomme.
Wollen wir mal ein bisschen erklärt wird wie das ding eigentlich so technisch aufgebaut ist also wie die mulle kühl struktur des virus ist und,
tatsächlich also es ist ja diese ringförmig also dieses kronenarchitektur deswegen nennt man diese gattung ja auch corona viren.
Und ein teil dieser moleküle die das eben diesen ring zusammenhalten sind die peter und die reagieren halt sozusagen sehr negativ auf alles was so fettlösend ist.
Sprich wenn du mit seife daherkommt was hochgradig fettlösend ist wird der virus einfach zerstört also es geht gar nicht so sehr bei diesem händewaschen das fehlt mir immer so ein bisschen in der diskussion gar nicht so sehr um.
Ich befreie jetzt meine hände von viren und dann sind die im abfluss sondern es geht tatsächlich.
Bei dem händewaschen mit seife um die tatsächliche zerstörung des virus und deswegen ist das so effizient und finde es ganz lustig weil ich hatte.
Wie so viele auch mir natürlich über richtige hände wascht techniken so nie gedanken gemacht kam aber lustigerweise gerade zum ende des jahres das erste mal auf das thema weil da leute.
Um bei dem bei dem kongress am ende des jahres wo wir immer sind auch viele leute dann in der küche mithelfen sollen.
Und damit sie das irgendwie dürfen und die richtige basis haben.
Hört mal nochmal schnell zum gesundheitsamt und lässt sich so ein paar stunden einführungskurs geben dann kriegt man irgendwie so einen zettel so nach dem motto ja okay ist hier mit den grundlagen von hygiene und wie man sich so verhalten sollte wenn man lebensmittel für viele leute herstellt
damit vertraut gemacht worden und ein teil davon ist eben auch richtig hände waschen also wird dieser prozess mit
nichts vergessen und der daumen und fingerspitzen und so weiter finde ich da irgendwie schon ganz interessant weil es ja immer bei so veranstaltungen so mitten im winter auch mal ein härteres thema ist so gerade auf dem kongress gibt's die sprichwörtliche,
kongress solche.
Ja und jetzt konnte ich das wissen dann gleich praktisch anwenden und auf einmal ist das ganze internet voll mit hand waschanleitung kann man sich auf jeden fall nochmal anschauen wenn man das noch nicht ausreichend gemacht.
Bei mir ich habe so ein bisschen drin dadurch dass ich halt öfter am motorrad schraube und die hände dann dreckig sind so,
überall muss man dann schon die richtigen techniken einfach anwenden um dann halt den schmutz einfach überall wo er ist auch entfernt zu kriegen man meint es fingerspitzen und daumen,
und so und ja ja aber ja ja aus auswirkungen ich meine,
er hat gut rassistische schuldzuweisung kam natürlich auch noch so mit ganz am anfang na ja das waren es sagen die.
Der der chinesen virus aber nicht nicht nur sondern es waren dann je nachdem wo man sich gerade dann dann befand waren's dann halt sagen ja,
die ausländer oder bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen also in china war dann ja auch in china in italien war ja dann auch erstmal wegen der wegen der ganzen
chinesen so waren die erstmal in verdacht die ganzen illegalen chinesischen arbeiter hätten das da eingeschleppt so wobei man festgestellt hat dass es.
In der community gar nix war erstaunlicherweise also.
Die reisen auch in der regel nicht so viel international.
Ja naja wobei die üblicherweise schon wohl irgendwie gerne nach deutschland reisen als touristen.
Nach china.
Die chinesen nach deutschland und dann sagen um in in in italien dann für drei monate zu jobben so das ist sozusagen sondern.
Okay gut.
Muster in irgendwelchen textilfabrik und.
Ja gut und jetzt natürlich in den in den usa sind es natürlich jetzt auch erstmal ja,
die europäer die nicht mehr kommen dürfen weil das jetzt.
Erstmal ja die die ausländer die übrigens halt rein und natürlich hat man auch gesehen so afd hat das natürlich auch versucht für sich
zu nutzen scheint aber nicht so richtig verfangen zu sein aber natürlich gerade bei der klientel
die er so auch dann zu weiß ich nicht ekel oder angst vor irgendwie keimen und so neigt.
Ja ja das ist also da gibt es gibt sozusagen schon verbindungen zwischen sagen politischer einstellung und angst vor keimen so ja ja.
Ernsthaft achso ist trump eigentlich auch so.
Und ja und man kann tatsächlich sogar auch durch eindämmung von infektionskrankheiten also mit antibiotika kann man halt tatsächlich auch rassismus bekämpfen so hat man fest gestellt oder.
Ja
Nochmal was kann man.
Ja das hat sich gezeigt dass sagen die die angst vor fremden ist
in gesellschaften wo halt infektionskrankheiten verbreitet
sind so besteht halt einen grund misstrauen einfach gegenüber fremden und gegenüber allen fremden und kann man auch ganz gut ich beim frank hat ja mal nach
gefragt wie oft twitter was es denn so an literatur gibt eigentlich aus so solchen zeiten so beschreibungen wie welchen einfluss das dann hatte und,
war dann halt schon so dass dann das damals üblich war wenn du wenn dann ein fremder in die stadt gekommen ist so in in solchen zeiten wurden die erstmal eine woche oder zwei irgendwo am,
am brand in quarantäne gestellt selbst auch bei der spanischen grippe noch also vor vor hundert jahren war.
Aber da wahrscheinlich nicht ohne grund.
Nicht nicht ohne grund aber tatsächlich ist es so dass wenn man jetzt sagen die zahl der infektionskrankheiten schafft,
zu reduzieren das dann auch sagen die ja also fremdenfeindlichkeit tatsächlich zurückgeht so da gibt es interessante untersuchungen.
Trotzdem haben sie dann auch so einen hohen anteil an an impfgegnern und irgendwie also.
Das ist dann wieder wohlstandsverwahrloste.
Ja
Ja na ja gott mal gucken wenn ich meine und das passt ja jetzt auch wieder schön ins bild wo du schon sagtest so positive auswirkungen umwelt et cetera.
Wir haben ja auch diese diesen krasse wissenschafts- verleugnung.
Gehabt oder haben sie noch immer so die auch so teil des politischen diskurses ist so dieses.
Hat man auch beim brexit so dieses jahr experten haben uns hier mal gar nichts zu sagen wir haben
viel zu lange auf experten verlassen und klimawandel und so ihr mit euren wissenschaftlern und habe da auch gar kein realitätsbezug und wir wissen es ja alles viel besser,
und ich habe den eindruck dass die bereitschaft auf wissenschaftler zu hören in den letzten tagen dann doch ein bisschen zugenommen hat.
Was in gewisser hinsicht vielleicht einiges wettmachen könnte.
Was so diese generelle diskreditierung von wissenschaft betrifft weil ich denke mal ohne wissenschaft wäre es wahrscheinlich alle tot.
Also nicht nur wegen des virus sondern auch wie.
Allen anderen die gesamten medizinischen grund zustände von denen wir doch eigentlich permanent profitieren so also,
gerade im bereich impfung das führt einfach dazu dass dass wir doch.
Weitgehend unbesorgt ist dasein fristen können so also als gesamtgesellschaft natürlich.
Mir fällt gerade noch nochmal einsprung zurück ein,
punkt der mir gerade noch noch auffällt auch von denen jetzt auswirkungen sind zwar jetzt vielleicht nicht die langfristigen auswirkungen aber die mittelfristigen auswirkungen von so einem shutdown,
und zwar ist es ja jetzt notwendig um.
Also veranstaltungen sagen nach dem zeitraum.
Des des des shutdown müssen aber während der zeit des shutdown geplant werden was zum teil auch nicht möglich ist sodass wir
jetzt wahrscheinlich auch mit einer welle von absagen von großen veranstaltungen rechnen können nicht weil angst besteht das dann sagen,
die noch infiziert sein könnten sondern weil im moment eine planung oder vorbereitung nicht möglich ist das trifft zum beispiel wohl auf dem csd
zu habe ich gehört und sogar irgendwie europameisterschaft ist glaube ich in gefahr weil er so im.
Gründen.
Im fußball und andere dinge auch das heißt was wir halt auch möglicherweise erleben werden ist selbst wenn danach,
sagen wieder zur normalität zurück gekehrt wird das dann erst mal ja viele dinge die dann eigentlich hätten stattfinden sollen nicht stattfinden können weil man nicht in der lage war die zu planen oder oder vorzubereiten.
Aber ja andere sache könnte natürlich sein ob dann irgendwann nicht in der zweiten jahreshälfte oder im sommer sagen ein großer nachholbedarf
kommt das wäre dann auch sagen dass dann eine große party gefeiert wird dann danach erstmal wenn alles.
Überstanden ist ja aber.
Mit dem fußball ist natürlich interessant er will kein fußball fußball podcast raus machen.
Aber es ist ja nun mal so dass das so ein bisschen auch einerseits so ein herz der.
Aktivität für viele leute ist sei es dass man selber spielt oder einfach nur am spiel bewundern teilnimmt und und so was wie so ein europameisterschaft findet nicht statt.
Gehört so in dieser kategorie kann man sich eigentlich überhaupt nicht vorstellen oder olympia in japan steht das glaube ich an ja es ist genau dasselbe problem und kann gut sein dass dieses jahr.
Weitgehend ohne meister und so weiter ausgespielt wird.
Ja also gerade beim beim fußball ich meinen fußball ist ja nicht nur unterhaltung sondern.
Ein wirtschaftsbetriebe erster güte.
Ja und aber auch ein politikum oder eine gesellschaft
relevante institution schon also erstens nicht ohne grund spielt fußball auch in der politik
eine große rolle im abgeordnetenhaus auch auch gemerkt so zwischen mal dann den hertha und union fans und so bestanden dann doch gewaltige politische abgründe teilweise,
aber ohne so ganz ohne fußball oder also so sagen als lang,
nicht fußballfan in der politik ist so ein bisschen wie als atheistin der amerikanischen politik habe ich das gefühl in in deutschland und wir haben auch alle immer sagen
raushängen lassen oder eingestreut sozusagen welche ja.
Bei welchem team sie jetzt da gerade so also ja.
Vertretbar du kannst fan von jedem sein aber bloß nicht von keimen.
Herr plus das ist natürlich auch also sport generell über solche sportlichen wettbewerbs sind ja auch so ein bisschen kriegs ersetz sage ich mal so man,
dann so dinge einfach sportlich aus statt dass man dann sich sich wirklich irgendwie jetzt gewalttätig also insofern ist es sagen auch nicht zu unterschätzen so wirtschaft oder oder oder sport sagen als friedens
projekte oder als friedens erhaltene maßnahme und wenn das nicht stattfindet so ist sicherlich auch nicht.
Zumindest langfristig nicht.
Ja also auch ja.
Der wirtschaftsbetriebe fußball ist natürlich auch interessant weil er eben auch auf diese zyklen angewiesen ist du hast ja.
Nicht so wie die normale wirtschaft so okay gut da ist er mal weihnachten da wird ein bisschen mehr verkauft oder so aber
dieses ganze sportliche gefüge kann überhaupt nicht funktionieren wenn du somit aufstieg und abstieg zu tun hast ja weil ich würde jetzt zum beispiel die bundesliga-saison
vorzeitig beendet werden was durchaus droht und zwar glaube ich
zwar wollen sie lieber jetzt sozusagen mit zuschauer freien spielen das ding zu ende bringen so dass schmerz zwar finanziell und es schmerzt auch natürlich von der ganzen
stimmung her aber noch schlimmer wäre sozusagen keine planungssicherheit mehr zu haben war ja im prinzip das gesamte liga modell auseinanderbricht
also hast du keine kontinuität man muss dann vielleicht am ende beschließen so ja,
vorzeitig alles beendet nächstes jahr nächste saison machen wir wieder genau,
spielen wir dieselbe saison nochmal so und damit wirst du natürlich auch wenig freunde machen also klar die die abgestiegen werden die finden das natürlich super.
Aber die die potenziell aufgestiegen werden haben natürlich dann auch wieder den scheiß.
Und natürlich für einen union fan wie dich ist das natürlich oder für alle union fans gerade natürlich besonders schlechtes timing weil glaube ich ja eigentlich bayern unter anderem kommt und das derby.
Ja das bayernspiel ist an der stelle glaube ich weniger relevant als die ganzen derbys die halt jetzt also alle es gibt ja immer viele dörfer sowohl schalke dortmund ist an diesem wochenende,
köln gegen gladbach war jetzt gerade und nächste woche halt härter gegen union und das ist natürlich dann immer schon so ein bisschen auch die highlights naja,
fußball aber es am ende wahrscheinlich noch das verzichtbar erste von allem.
Da sind dann andere sachen schwieriger und ich freue mich halt wie kann sich das auf die psyche der gesellschaft auswirken.
Also ist das sozusagen jetzt eher
so ein wir herzog das gesagt hat so ein ruck der durch die gesellschaft geht man kann's ja auch positiv ist ausmalen sagen ja da kommen die leute mal wieder zusammen naja okay nicht
wirklich bei
ansteckungsgefahr aber man ist halt gegebenenfalls wieder mehr auf nachbarschaftshilfe angewiesen um jetzt die versorgung sicherzustellen da sieht man jetzt auch schon die ersten initiativen,
komm du hast die anderen ausrüstung schon du angesprochen hast so opportunisten die dann halt einfach mal das klopapier klauen und so.
Sozusagen sich da auch kriminell noch was ausdenken wie man aus der situation was positives rausziehen kann.
Die andere frage ist gibt's halt auch potentiell deprimierende auswirkungen.
Naja naja es ist gut es ist natürlich erstmal eine kulturelle verarmung oder kultur entzug.
Der stattfindet und auch geselligkeit entzug des.
Kann dann natürlich wieder auch zu einer wenn ich möglicherweise zu einer zunahme von depressionen oder wie auch immer,
führen also gut ist es sicherlich nicht wenn die leute nicht miteinander so ja und.
Weniger umarmungen und küsse und so ist auch keine gute sache definitiv nicht ja gut vielleicht.
Positiv drehen möchte vielleicht wissen wir dann hinterher was wir denn alles alles dran
haben so und so wissen es dann besser zu schätzen aber es kann natürlich auch so zu verlängerungseffekt führen dass die leute irgendwie jetzt noch mehr vor der glotze
hängen einfach wieder wo die fernsehkonsum hat wohl deutlich schon zugenommen und.
Wenn sie mehr jetzt e-sports betreiben um nicht jetzt von computerspielen zu reden.
Ändert sich auch im kinderzimmer wieder was kinder geht doch mal in euer zimmer und spielt mit mehr mit dem computer hier hängt ja gar nicht von youtube rum.
Und ja ich weiß nicht dann bewegungsmangel oder so hat sicherlich dann auch keine
guten auswirkungen wenn die leute in ihren buden hocken das macht auch depressiv wenn du nicht rausgehst dani rausgehen kannst an die frische luft also
insofern also toll ist es ist es ist das alles nicht gut vielleicht,
vielleicht hilft es uns einfach so ein bisschen mal uns bewusst zu werden dass es auch
ziemlich scheiße sein kann und sagen mehr zu schätzen sagen den den wohlstand und die normalität und den frieden den wir so,
lange genießen können dass das nicht alles so selbstverständlich oder gott
gegeben ist vielleicht werden wir ja im im zuge dessen auch dann in deutschland endlich in krankenhäusern die hygiene maßnahmen soweit
verbessert kriegen wie die holländer das auch mit halt den ja mit dem krankenhaus killer keimen
so das man ja.
Anderes problem aber auf jeden fall auch eins ja.
Ja und ja vielleicht ja.
Weniger weniger selbstverständlich weniger dinge als selbstverständlich annehmen also insofern kann es vielleicht auch ein bisschen,
heilsam sein plus ja.
Hätte ich zwar schon gesagt dass man ein bisschen mehr auf resilienz achtet dass man auch bei wertschöpfungsketten überlegt dass es vielleicht schon sinnvoll ist nicht nur
nach auf geld hin zu optimieren sondern auch um die frage so was was müssen wir eigentlich,
im land in der lage sein produzieren zu können um sagen
in notfällen auch nicht die bevölkerung zu gefährden ich meine da ist speziell medikamenten produktion in meinem selbst bevor das ganze angefangen hat
haben wir leute die in krankenhäusern arbeiten gesagt dass sie teilweise ja zig medikamente die eigentlich zum standard gehören
so im moment nicht vorrätig sind und dass sie dann teilweise auf andere mittel ausweichen müssen und da aber
um die patienten nicht unbedingt besonders gut mit klar kommen das heißt wir hatten eigentlich schon,
in gewissen medikamenten versorgungs- notstand bei bei medikamenten bevor das alles angefangen hat und vielleicht ja.
Überlegt sich dann doch die bundesregierung oder auch auch die eu dass man sagt okay bestimmte dinge.
Eine bestimmte art von produktion brauchen wir hier einfach auch wir können nicht alles nach china auslagern.
Der finanzkrise hatten wir in diesem schönen begriff des system kritischen bank.
Wir können nicht einfach die bank jetzt hier den bach runter gehen lassen weil dieses system kritisch weil da gibt's gar kein geld mehr wer soll es dann das geld durchreichen was sowieso von der zentralbank kommt.
Das könnte jetzt die debatte was eigentlich system kritisch ist im sinne von was erhält uns denn konkret am leben auch nochmal neu entfachen also so die debatte kritische infrastruktur.
Lustig ist
auch plötzlich wie die banken dann jetzt in den hintergrund treten in italien würde jetzt diskutiert ich weiß nicht ob's beschlossen wurde aber aussetzen von raten
sagen bei bei krediten dass die leute sagen offiziell davon freigestellt werden ihre kredite bedienen zu müssen also speziell bei immobilien-darlehen war das glaube ich irgendwie der
der fall dass in italien nicht gekündigt werden jetzt wegen.
Bei in italien auch einen hohen anteil an eigentumswohnungen hat das heißt da ist der mit zins bei uns ist dort eigentlich der der kredit zins.
Da macht das nochmal eine extra rolle spielen.
Gut pavel vorher noch weiter hosttest mal wieder voneinander trennen hier unter einsatz unseres lebens nehmen wir hier einen podcast auf.
Vielleicht besuchen wir das thema.
Die tage nochmal ich habe so den eindruck hier könnte sich noch ein bisschen was tun vielleicht löst sich ja auch alles in wohlgefallen auf und deine ganzen berechnungen sind einfach quatsch auch sein.
Das wäre also das wäre mir dass das liebste so wenn sagen meine.
Ja meine befürchtungen sich dann doch in wohlgefallen auflösen im moment sehe ich aber eher so dass wir in ich sag mal ein,
irgendwann in ein bis drei wochen hier ausgangssperren kriegen
werden und alle schulen dicht gemacht werden und alle restaurants das erwarte ich eigentlich im moment wär schön wenn es nicht passiert so
aber ja plus dass ich nicht glaube dass wir,
dass die kapazitäten unseres gesundheitssystems ausreichen werden um alle patienten dann gut versorgen zu können also ich fürchte das steht uns auch bevor zumindest eine temporäre
überlastung und sehr hässliche bilder dann in den in den medien von irgendwie hustende kranken die dann auf dem flur liegen und sich darüber beschweren
haben wir ja jetzt schon,
so leute die irgendwie fünf tage lang von pontius zu pilatus geschickt wurden bevor sie getestet werden konnten und so gut,
vielleicht aber wird sich das man wird sich das auch also oder so rum,
ich glaube wiederum um um auch auf was positives zu enden egal wie schlimm es kommt so wir werden's überleben.
Und wir werden uns glaube ich,
einstellen so ein bisschen wie weiß nicht ob sich an die sogenannte flüchtlingskrise erinnerst wo dann auch erstmal chaos groß war,
aber irgendwann so mit einem leider ein bisschen mit verzögerung kam dann doch irgendwie alles in in die gänge und in tritt und dann hat man es doch irgendwie dann ja
so nach einem halben jahr oder so lief das dann so man konnte sie alle unterbringen und versorgen und so auch,
der ganze papierkram wurde irgendwann aufgearbeitet und so stelle ich mir das hier halt auch vor so es wird erstmal chaotisch und alle werden sich,
angst haben und so aber irgendwann.
Ist es normal.
Irgendwann werden wir es halt in in den griff kriegen und damit umgehen können irgendwann gibts dann den impfstoff und dann ja.
Da gibt's auch wieder fußball.
Dann gibt's mal wieder fußball und wir können wieder beruhigt in die kneipe gehen ja.
Gut das war's außer metaebene hier in eurer verschluss bereiche noch könnt ihr euch ja ein bisschen bewegen nutzt die gelegenheit und ansonsten.
Tschüss.